i just came back from new york where my
kids uh were uh in in high school right
and i see the stark differences in
culture here and there
um and i think that it's the culture and
it's the military
and other things that created this
amazing
tech industry in israel
that's becoming more powerful more
diverse more mature and more impactful
welcome to 20 minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today it's a journey each one is
different unique inspiring let's get
started
[Music]
this episode is powered by j ventures a
community driven vc fund in silicon
valley in partnership with lomitek and
sponsored by homework ventures hippo
insurance opposed hillel stanford leap
and birthright excel an in media
partnership with ctec
welcome to 20 minute leaders i am so
incredibly excited to share this episode
with you because i'm going to be talking
to one of the people that i admire most
in this professional and personal world
nadaftafrio previously commander of 8200
an incredible incredible life journey
and today the co-founder of team 8 and
managing partner of teammate platform
nadav is focused on driving global
growth for teammates and is the
architect of team 8's relationships
across the business academic and
technology worlds nadav's experience has
positioned him well to help define the
opportunities and challenges in today's
technology marketplace
welcome nadav
[Music]
welcome to 20 minute leaders how are you
thanks good awesome well i think you
need to look at me this is a beautiful
beautiful office where the teaming
office is in tel aviv
but you're you're mostly based in new
york up until now and because you've
built an empire and and i have to say
nadav from a on a personal note you're a
legend i mean both in my five years in
8200 but now also in the tech scene here
especially in israel i mean the word
nadarza frida is you know it resonates
and it makes a ripple effect a long ways
and so i'm excited in these 20 minutes
to both
you know go back in time a little bit
about your own journey your personal
journey and you know what does it mean
for you to be a leader and you know how
do you take all these different things
that you decide to do and you do them so
exceptionally well and inspire others
around you so i that's that's all the
talking that i'm gonna do i'm gonna
leave the photo to you tell me a little
bit i think we're good i think that's
that's as that's as good as it's going
to get i think we can stop here um
you know
i like to look at the world as a uh
as a place of opportunity so basically i
categorize myself as an opportunist
i'm constantly looking at the way the
world works
um at the way the people act and i'm
trying to figure out uh
opportunities challenges
and when i do i get obsessed about it um
and so i try to share that with other
people
um because i usually don't think about
big thoughts myself i have to think big
thoughts with uh
smart people hopefully much smarter than
i am which i usually surround myself
with future people that are much more
talented and smart and knowledgeable
um and to find hacks into the future you
know what's the future going to look
like and how can we try to predict
and do something today that would be
relevant for the future and how can i
inspire other people that again are more
talented smarter uh and knowledgeable
so that together we can do something
about it so that's
basically the story of uh what i do so
the elite started with elite commando in
the army one of the most incredible
units that anybody can ever dream of
getting into but then you didn't stop
there you moved on to after many years
becoming the commander of the 8200
organization that is obviously well
known around the world for to be a
leading cyber security arm within israel
and then you didn't stop there but you
went to go and co-found into the
managing partner of team eight
tell me a little bit about you know your
army experience you know when you go
into the army do you know that a few
dozen years down the line you're gonna
be the commander of 8200 is that sort of
a goal because it started in combat no
honestly uh you know i didn't grow up in
israel i grew up in south america uh i
came to israel when i was 18. wow
and uh three weeks later i was doing uh
uh my basic training in uh uh in in the
paratroopers
wow um so from
um you know from a nice uh um
american international school in south
america
uh to sanu
it was a big change and i honestly had
no idea where i was going to go
but there's something incredible about
the idf uh which is it's a real melting
pot so for someone that didn't grow up
in this country to immediately get into
this melting pot and see all the
different people and
perspectives uh religions you know i
served with the bedouins with jerus with
people from all over the country so it
was a very intense
uh uh experience for me uh and i i fell
in love with this uh um the fact that i
felt it gave me new opportunities all
the time
and uh uh you know the military for me
was first of all on a personal basis
really good
the people that i met were incredible
along the way
almost in every chapter of the journey
and
when i look back at my 25 25 years of
service i'm probably one of the luckiest
bastards that ever joined the idf
because i found myself
in areas where
things were reaching
a kind of a plateau in terms of their
relevance
and since what i like to do is try to
look into the future understand what
we're doing right now and try to plan
for the future for me it was disneyland
i mean so one of the reasons i mentioned
before that the name of that sofia is a
legend especially in the army because we
you know when we think of nadas we it's
a pioneer in the cyber security space
leading a new era of what it means to
work in the cyber space but i want to go
back to that moment that you're 18 three
weeks into landing in israel you find
yourself in the paratroopers you know i
i remember my entrance into the idf and
i i grew up in most of my time in israel
it's hard i mean the transition is hard
mentally it's hard
what is what is the personality trait
that you look back to that you know you
that you look so optimistically about
that you know the boot camp you're not
sleeping you're not eating you're
running you it it's really hard no
that's i don't want to sugarcoat it and
and when i was in uh sanur was uh
okay
which is the next stage was pretty
miserable so let's not sugarcoat it you
know i as a child growing up i was uh i
was what today you would consider
a geek
uh um you know i got my first computer i
think in nineteen
probably 1981 or two wow it was a
commodore 64.
uh and i started coding in in basic and
it blew my mind it blew my mind that you
could actually write something and the
machine would do something and so you
know i spent a lot of time doing that so
when i came to israel and they asked me
what i like to do i said you know
um
i like computers
and when as i was jumping out of
perfectly good airplanes i always try to
understand you know what's the what's
the connection here wow
but years later
uh when i joined the special ops within
the intelligence um
i was i was fascinated by what they were
doing there and i was always
sort of the geek within the team
so whenever there was something
technological i would sort of focus on
it
and it served me really well in the end
of the 90s because in the end of the 90s
internet was a new phenomena
and the intelligence was trying to
figure out what that would mean for
intelligence going forward right what
what is this new phenomena this new way
of interacting that's slowly becoming
more ubiquitous how is that going to
affect the world
and
i was lucky to meet a a you know
a good friend that became my mentor guy
seda
and guy stella was at that time deputy
commander in uh
unit 81 which now i understand we're
allowed to talk about
and uh um
and i was a special ops guy but you know
he showed me this paper and he said look
this is what the future of intelligence
is going to look like wow here's what
telecommunications systems are going to
be going through here is the internet
and here's how things are going to
change and this is my vision
and that became sort of a blueprint
for many of the initiatives that the
intelligence started to work on
and it led to a very a very fast pace of
change
and it led to new ways of collaborating
between 81 and 82 between 81 82 and
mossad between 81 82 mossad and shabbat
and all that became sort of a multiplier
and i was very very lucky i was very
lucky because
amongst the combat guys i was considered
a really good technologist
and amongst the technology guys i was
considered a superior
combat guy yeah
i was mediocre at both but it turned out
that they were looking for someone that
could sort of take these two things
together because it was believed back
then that in order to do operations in
the internet what now we call cyber you
need the operations background mentality
theory etc
and so i joined guysela
in 81 we built the first couple of teams
we we started bringing people in and we
started exploring you know with this new
phenomena that was called the internet
and you know we were
sort of at
we were just a you know a sliver of what
the whole picture was
but as we grew it we understood the
relevance and the potential
um and at the same time another
phenomenon happened that had nothing to
do with technology which is that our
rivals
also changed so nation states from
nation states and strategic early
warning we saw a shift into
non-native states quasi-nation states
terrorism became
ubiquitous and a big threat not just in
use a nuance or a nuisance
um and iran became you know the
sort of the the top uh uh at the top of
our agenda and where we no longer have
a border
uh uh with them so now we need to to
deal with these quasi-nation state
terrorist uh groups uh so it's many
and now we need to to deal with far
which is iran
and all of these are starting to get
more and more comfortable with taking
advantage of this new phenomena that we
call the internet which gives them
state-of-the-art command and control
that they are
leveraging uh very fast at zero cost
and then comes 911.
wow
and when you look at 911 you realize for
the maybe for the first time how this
command and control system
that has nothing to do with terrorism
nation-states strategic advancing etc
serves a group of very sophisticated uh
um terrorists in this case
that probably take out the you know the
most notorious biggest uh uh um
terrorist attack ever and when you look
back you understand that the command and
control under this is mostly through the
internet which i claim they could not
have done without the invention of the
internet wow
and so all this came together
and we started to take advantage of it
for our uh our cause
and that's sort of the birth of what
today we call cyber now today you look
at every organization you look at and
you know most leaders talk about
innovation right and it's something that
is very open and it's something that we
talk about a lot how do you do
innovation within big corporates it's
something that many many companies are
struggling with but i'm taking you back
20 years or this word innovation within
a corporate and innovation in
bureaucracy is not something that is
still you know very common and there's
no real you know blueprints and and and
books about how to do that yet you're in
a leadership position
and obviously looking back you've done
it very very successfully you know in
leadership positions within these elite
units
what is it distilled to how do you how
do you bring innovation within research
and development not just in a
bureaucratic company in a military
setting in perhaps one of the most
structured companies in the world yeah
you know it's counterintuitive
but innovations in organizations like
is very simple
for um for a very unique reason and if
you ask me what i miss from the military
it's this
it's the fact that you have
direct
no compete
access to the most brilliant minds in a
on a nation-state level
in an evergreen process
um and that is unmatched in any other
organization in the world what what blew
my mind and what i think 8200 figured
out first and better than any other
organization within the military or in
the world
is that the fact that you have mandatory
service
and the fact that mandatory service
means that you can start screening young
individuals while they're still in high
school
in the optimal time in their lives
and if you can
manage to take advantage of that to
leverage that to build on that
nothing will stop you and so in 8200 and
81 today and other organizations it's
the the biggest secret is that it's a
bottom-up innovation process
we used to think that leadership should
show you know
not only where we want to go
but also help you figure out how to get
there right and when i joined the
military that was pretty much it because
you know the people that made the
hardest toughest most important
decisions in the military environment
were the people that had the most
experience
that doesn't hold true anymore
for for a few reasons reason number one
is that the environment changed right
and so in many ways sometimes when
you're dealing with quasi nation state
terrorist attacks etc somebody that just
joined the military a year ago will make
the most important decision on the field
that's number one number two which is
more important
leaders used to be able not just to
inspire and tell people where to go but
help them understand how to go there
as the pace of change of the environment
the technology the way these two
interact accelerated dramatically
leaders could no longer tell
anyone how to get to anywhere
so the most you can do as a leader is
say look
here's reality
here's what we want
and this would be a good outcome now if
you ask me uh and you are an 8200 if you
ask me now hey but nadav you're the
leader or you're the commander of 800
can you tell me how to get there my
answer is i haven't got a clue
how to get there
why well first of all because nobody's
ever gone there
second because the technology changes as
we speak
and so what does that mean right it
means that if you
choose the right people with the right
aptitude
and you don't try to understand what
they know right now but how fast they
can learn new tricks and adjust
right and you create the right
environment the right infrastructure the
the right culture
you start realizing that those
individuals will show you how to get
there
and that every once in a while there
will be a tremendous breakthrough in a
place where nobody even understands that
that is possible and that gives you the
advantage for a while
you know in a world in a military world
that is adversarial right
um and so when you make that
breakthrough
based on young
smart motivated individuals that one of
their biggest attributes is the lack of
experience
and you know in in many ways they're
naivete right that gives you the
advantage and in a world where you're
constantly recruiting the best and the
brightest kids from high school
in an evergreen process
that is a that is a
is a is a drive that is unprecedented i
remember my mind was constantly blown
with this dissonance that you know i had
to fill all these weekly quarterly
monthly reports about
are we meeting our kpis as a unit as a
team leader where i have you know quite
a few steps until i get to talk to the
commander of 8200 about my work and i
and they were taking even that's more
the structure of bureaucracy but then i
was always i always knew that if i had
an idea where i had to divert from the
structure but it was an innovative idea
that could potentially have a one
percent chance of succeeding i have full
full autonomy to go and do it and my
whole chain of command is going to start
right and you also mentioned the one
percent right that means that in 99 of
the cases you will fail so you need to
create a failure tolerant environment
right so if you create an environment
where it's
fairly fairly flat everybody understands
the uh um the vision
uh more or less
people understand what you want from
them more or less
and you inspire them to explore
and you act and you really
create a failure tolerant and the saying
that we're failure tolerant is very easy
taking the chances and giving the
support and taking the you know taking
in the the the
the
understanding that there may be
serious consequences and living with
that embracing that
um is tough
um and i think 8200 has that sort of a
goldilocks area where it is really
failure tolerant and it really inspires
young individuals to take
chances
uh uh and to constantly push
the envelope or to country constantly
puts the borders of what you're already
doing by the way one thing that i would
tell leaders is you know tell them
here's where we want you to go we don't
know how to get there just don't tell
them that we've tried a dozen times and
failed
you know keep them
that naivete works in your favor right
right and magic happens right if you
have that ability
to uh recall the right people from the
high schools um and you have a a you
know a very short loop to understand if
your prediction actually worked
then your precision constantly gets
higher i love it right and and sort of
we were doing machine learning without
understanding that we were doing just
about to say now what is all this what
does all this mean now so today you're
working with founders you're working
with leadership teams within cyber
companies that you either help create or
invest in
taking all this experience whether it's
from command to special forces south
america to you know leading the the
cyber organization of the of israel you
know what does this mean today with team
eight
well you know
it's it it goes beyond team eight and
and and then sort of uh obviously that's
where i spend most of my time but if you
think about it generally from a very
strategic level on a global level
we have seen unprecedented change uh and
i think we haven't seen anything
right i do believe that we are about to
eat to hit the hockey stick effect of
the exponential effect of digital
and digital transformation
um and i think that in some ways we are
going to experience what we did
somewhere in 2007 or 2008 where
by you know by coincidence different
technologies matured at the same time i
think we are at a
display at a place where this happens if
you think about uh um ai and machine
learning and the potential of uh new
technologies and the cloud that has
become you know the
totally uh are prevalent in ubiquitous
etc i think we haven't seen anything yet
i think covid kovit
accelerated all that dramatically and
sort of brought the time closer to where
we are right now and i think we're going
to see great change so
from that perspective i think technology
digital digital transformation uh is
going to have a larger effect than ever
on our lives
um i think that what we've seen in the
last two years just gives us a glimpse
of what's possible right if you if you
just look at the last two years i mean
we transformed from
95 percent of the people working in an
office space
to 95 of the people working remotely uh
based on a digital infrastructure that
if you would have asked me two years ago
you know what do you think is there a
possibility that everybody's going to
work from home and the world will still
be running more or less my answer would
be no way this is going to collapse but
here it is right uh we have managed to
do two things that are uh bring a lot of
optimism for me at least one is the fact
that we we we've managed to work
remotely through this global pandemic
and two
if you if you look at the the advances
uh in medicine and specifically the
ability to come up with vaccines in an
unprecedented uh short time a lot of
this has to do with the access to data
and the ability to process data
on using uh you know farley far better
abilities to uh to process the data to
store the data the algorithms that come
in it etc and i think that's going to
affect every field of life from climate
and energy
um to medicine to cyber to e-commerce to
mobility all these are going to be
affected dramatically so that's from a
global perspective and i want to take
this one step further you know we we're
in israel in a place of you know i call
it privilege or luxury where we got to
experience life you know in the physical
sense and we and we got we had a pretty
good life we could have gone to the
doctor we could go to the supermarket
the reality is that the majority of
people in the world don't have access to
a doctor in their city and and you know
with this whole digitalization we're
actually bringing in billions of people
into our economy and into that a little
bit than we knew before okay absolutely
and but we have another privileges
israelis
we're at the forefront today
of the ability to have a global impact
to actually make
billions of lives more uh um you know
included
uh informed and hence better more
meaningful healthy etc and israel in in
different fields is at the forefront of
that yes and that's not just you know
that's just not not just privilege that
also brings a lot of responsibility by
the way going back to our discussion
about 8200
i think and the military generally
speaking i think is one of the pillars
of where we are today yes and you know
when we create when we had when we
decided as a nation
you know
back in 19 back in the 40s that we need
mandatory service nobody thought that
that would create the actual uh
driver of the israeli economy but here
we are you know many decades later and
the actual the fact that we have
mandatory service in my opinion is also
responsible for the fact that we have
this amazing uh technological uh
advantage innovation advantage and one
aspect of it is that you have this
evergreen flow of people coming out of
8281 etc yeah right so what do they do
now you know if you look at their uh
calendar i just came back from new york
where my kids
were in in high school right
and
i see the stark differences in culture
here and there
um and i think that it's the culture and
it's the military
and other things that created this
amazing
tech industry in israel
um that's becoming uh more powerful more
diverse more mature and more impactful
right and so
when i look at the global of you know
problems opportunities challenges
whatever you want to call it when i look
at israel's position which is
unbelievably unique
uh and this evergreen push of talent
that comes from organizations like units
like 8200 and others there's an
opportunity here
um
one of the things that we realized in 80
in in team eight
is that this opportunity um is you know
you can look at the numbers you can look
at the impact this is a this is probably
the best time of the israeli tech
ecosystem ever however i think we can do
much better
i think we can do much better i think
that
early stage
ventures
uh haven't changed in the way they are
put together for decades in many ways
um the sieve that we we look at um to uh
to identify entrepreneurs is broken
um for for a few reasons i'll mention
two one is capital has become
commoditized and so the fact that
entrepreneurs needed to
compete for capital
today it's the opposite capital competes
for entrepreneurs right so what does
that mean
right what does that mean it means that
uh you have to find a new way
to deploy capital right
the second thing is the fact that
everybody is pretty much has access to
the same information
this leads to a plethora of
of you know
hundreds and thousands of startups
competing for the same budget right and
in my opinion this leads to two things
first of all
the the positioning of startups becomes
more and more narrow
and their ability to actually build
something with depth and strategy
is basically going back right and so
what we're trying to do in teammate is
address this phenomena
right we're trying we're building a
platform
that brings together the ability to
strategically understand
what's broken in areas where we believe
we actually understand you know we
started with cyber we then went into
data we then went into fintech and we're
going to go into other fields in the
near future unlike many funds it's
important to mention that we're in a
building with team eight and there's
dozens of people that work full time
with teammates not at the starts but
their researchers you know domain
experts in all these fields
trying to figure out what is the next
big thing that is going to impact the
world right this is so international
yeah in the natural what are we doing
right we're bringing
the the brightest uh accomplished
entrepreneurs and biz dev people and
marketing people and research people and
technologies to first try to identify
what's broken right and then we're
trying to create another
another meeting place or another form of
a meeting place between
challenges and problems
hungry talented capable entrepreneurs
and capital
why because we believe that this new
kind of match between these three
will lead to two things one dramatically
higher probability of success
and impact
that's it and we can see
so my pitch to entrepreneurs is very
very simple
capital is commoditized the ability to
appreciate what's strategically broken
and then bring the right resources in
the right time so that i can help you as
an entrepreneur to do two things one is
avoid unforced errors
and two
hop backs from errors that are
unavoidable
will create a path to success and impact
which with a dramatically higher
probability of success
i love it you know so you have the
company building and we didn't even
mention the community of csu that you
work with and the validation that you
get not just within the people that are
in this building but around the world
and some of the most incredible minds in
the world that are coming and helping
the early stage startups that you're
building with the incredible list of
successes already behind you and i
really want to thank you for inviting me
here i enjoyed this conversation so much
i have a few last questions about you
and i want to take you back to south
america elementary school middle school
you mentioned the commodore 64. you know
basic
what
commodore 64. i started with a dragon 32
by the way but yes
but what really fascinated you as a kid
you know what what really sparked your
curiosity is he went for even middle
school
you know it's it's
i was always you know first of all i was
uh my father was an entrepreneur
um
and the the one thing that he did uh at
a very early stage was experiment with
what back then
was the israeli tech which is dairy
farms okay right so he experimented with
the uh uh with
what is the nutrition that cows should
get in order to get a higher yield of
milk
and he claims uh and i've never been
able to check this that he brought the
first kyle in the world to go over 10
000 leaders a year wow okay so i grew up
in this environment where you're trying
to look at reality say here's reality
here's what we want the reality to look
like here's what we can do about it and
the fact that my parents moved from
country to country from culture to
culture actually
was was inspiring for me because you
know and and i and i grew up in third
world countries and when you grow up as
a kid in a third world country and you
and you travel to first world countries
the the you know the the this this
stark difference yes it's something that
you're saying well why are the people
here living like this and people here
living like this you know what how does
that make sense
uh uh or you know here's your problem
how do we solve so i was always
uh sort of trying to hack things uh not
from what today would be hacking um but
from a perspective um and the other is
uh uh you know
languages i've always been in i've
always been sort of it's
a freak of learning new languages it
could be computer languages human
languages etc by the way when i came to
8200 the one thing that blew my mind
first was how fast you can take somebody
with
zero arabic or persian and bring them to
be at the front line of the ones that
make decisions with regards to those
languages and so these are the things
that always have inspired me and so that
leads to the
to you know what inspires you today you
know not just with everything but today
in teammate or whether personally
professionally where do you gain your
inspiration to keep working so hard and
form many companies you're sitting on
the boards of so many companies okay i
stopped counting
what what what inspires you there
i'd say the following look the world is
screwed up right uh um you look at uh a
field that i'm uh working on today which
is cyber you look at climate change
um we from the one on the one side we
probably never had bigger challenges or
threats again look at cyber we're seeing
uh
enterprise and even smbs having to deal
with similar problems that only 10 years
ago nation states had to deal with
right on the other hand we're looking at
climate right and we're saying you know
uh uh we're almost at the end of a
really bad trajectory uh for the world
on the other hand
we have these incredible capabilities
which are also available to all right um
think about the world in the next 10
years when quantum computing becomes a
reality
and so what i'm inspired by is how do
you take these these incredible
challenges
uh um these unbelievable capabilities
and opportunities uh and try to avoid
these uh uh uh you know these stark uh
uh outcomes uh uh and sort of uh either
hack into the system or you know walk
around it so that we can have a better
uh a better outcome and for me
and i'm saying this not to uh uh um you
know one thing that you like that
there's a saying in 8200 which you
should probably heard
which is if you're the smartest person
in the room you're in the wrong room
you're in the wrong room right um
and so for me what's really inspiring is
trying to understand these strategic
trajectories that the world is going to
but identifying smart kids like yourself
and others
and try to uh uh
maybe mentor them uh at the best uh um
show them those opportunities
and help them do something about it
because believe me i was never the
smartest guy in the room
but trying to put together these minds
that have the critical mass
critical diverse mass of knowledge
uh inspiration whatever you want to call
it motivation
and do something about it whether it's
in cyber in energy in climate uh um
that's you know that's what gets me up
in bed from bed in the morning i love it
and if i would ask anybody here whether
it's
anybody in team eight or any of the
companies that you work with who is
nadav in two three words how would they
describe you uh
unfortunately they would tell you that
i'm chaotic okay i don't think they're
right
i don't think they're right by the way i
like to work at the edge of chaos okay
uh uh i don't believe in hierarchy and i
don't believe in a very rigid process
from somebody who's 25 years in the
military i i never believed in in rigid
processes i never believed believed in a
hierarchy uh because when you're
at a world that's changing so fast
you must leave a lot of balagam that's
one of the reasons that we're thriving
as a nation right because of the balagan
now of course if it's only balagan if
it's only chaos then it's entropy and
then there's nothing organized chaos if
you can do organized chaos or what in
the theory of complexity is called the
edge of chaos yeah unbelievable things
happen and sometimes they happen
naturally
theory complexity comes from nature like
the bees and whatever
and sometimes you just have to help it a
little bit and so what they would say is
that i'm very unstructured and uh at you
know sometimes chaotic i like to tell
them it's the edge of chaos and i'm just
gonna add the word leader because you
know this show i started at 20 minute
leaders trying to find leaders and what
makes them leaders and i gained so much
inspiration these more than 20 minutes
but i loved every second right so thank
you very much nadav thank you
great thanks bye
[Music]
you